Music
I'm overheating
Can't hardly sleep at night
Doing crazy dreaming
You're the reason why
Hiding by the baby
Losing my mind
Don't try to save me
I feel alive
My world is faster and faster
The tears in the laughter
I'm here for the ride
Yes, yes
I'm an emotional mess
Yes, but you wouldn't want me any less
Yes, cause you know how wild it could get
To love an emotional mess
I'm in a train
Spinning out of control
Don't know what this dance is
But at least I'm not dancing alone
Yes, yes, yes
Jesus, yes
It wouldn't wander
Yes, yes
Is doing
Yes, yes, I'm an emotional mess.
Yes, but you wouldn't want me any less.
Yes, cause you know how wild it could get to love an emotional mess.
You got me, babe, I'm yours to have.
Don't hurt me, my heart's in your hands.
Don't hurt me, baby.
You got me, babe, I'm yours to have.
Don't hurt me, my heart's in your hands.
Don't hurt me, baby.
Yes, yes, I'm an emotional mess.
Yes, but you wouldn't want me less.
Yes, I'm an emotional mess.
Yes, cause you know how wild it could get.
Yes, to love an emotional mess.
Yes, you wouldn't want me less.
Yes, cause you know how wild it could get.
To love an emotional mess.
Yes.
Yes, I'm overheating.
Can't hardly sleep at night.
Doing crazy dreaming.
You're the reason why.
Hiding by the baby.
Losing my mind.
Don't try to save me.
I feel alive.
My world is faster and faster.
The tears and the laughter.
I'm here for the ride.
Oh, yes, yes, I'm an emotional mess.
Yes, but you wouldn't want me less.
Yes, cause you know how wild it could get.
To love an emotional mess.
Oh, yes, against femals.
Yes.
Never Senator.
Never drink.
houseken بvat critique.
I'm in aastre.
Spinning out of control
Don't know what this dance is
But at least I'm not dancing alone
All kinds of crazy
You heard what I said
I blame you lover
I'm out of my head
Some days my fear has been frozen
I'm brave and I'm broken
My soul is wide open
Yes, yes, I'm an emotional mess
Yes, but you wouldn't want me any less
Yes, cause you know how wild it could get
To love an emotional mess
You got me, babe
I'm yours to have
Don't hurt me
My heart's in your hands
You got me, babe
I'm yours to have
Don't hurt me, baby
You got me, babe
I'm yours to have
Don't hurt me
My heart's in your hands
You got me, babe
I'm yours to have
Don't hurt me, babe
Yes, yes, I'm an emotional mess
Yes, yes, yes
But you wouldn't want me any less
Yes, I'm an emotional mess
Yes, cause you know how wild it could get
Yes, to love an emotional mess
Yes, yes, yes
You wouldn't want me any less
Yes, cause you know how wild it could get
To love an emotional mess
Yes
Yes, yes
Yes, yes, yes
Yes, yes, yes, yes
Thank you.